[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
we had tons of gaming channels in and
out of the office from
asus
royale
secret lab apol amongst other brands
and well let's face it gaming chairs
though they have their own unique
selling points they pretty much shared
the
[Laughter]
[Music]
they pretty much share the same
fundamental core elements like material
comfort their own patented foam core
padding
bucket style seats adjustable armrests
basically we can go on and on
so what makes this gaming chair that i'm
sitting on any different
is well
[Music]
okay
well to put it simply after a long day
of work or
an intense hardcore gaming session with
your friends
this chair gives you a damn good massage
damn
what's up everybody this is zacky from
geek culture and this is a video review
of the world's first
the world's first
predator x osim you throne gaming
massage chair
stay tuned
let's face it gaming can be pretty
intense and it can result in body pains
backaches from sitting too long or
hunching back over and let's face it my
fellow geeks we ain't got no time for
spotting so why not invest in a gaming
chair that kneads away all the aches and
pains am i right
yes
so not only does this chair look sleek
if it's two tone
black and icy blue finish but it's black
carbon fiber patterned pvc leatherette
just seals the deal
in making this
look like a proper proper gaming chair
you've got the predator logo embroidered
on the headrest as well as the predator
wordings on the side which just screams
you know gamer branding
and overall the material does feel very
plush and it's comfortable
oh man
[Music]
and you're probably asking yourself hey
zach
leather really doesn't it peel over time
well no actually well this chair has
undergone quality certification by a
company called bogen it's japan's
leading testing organization for textile
and lifestyle goods so this material
that's used on the youth throne is
durable dust resistant pliable water
resistant and high resistance to
humidity and light so you can be rest
assured that this chair will last you
for a very very
very
long time
[Music]
it sports an adjustable back and lumbar
support to fit your frame as well as a
removable
lumbar cushion
so you can enjoy a nice lower back
massage and the chair reclines up to 145
degrees
so you can take either net or very very
deep
tissue
massage
of course there are four
discrete rollers then massages from your
lower back to your neck and shoulders of
course you have your fully adjustable
height mechanism for stability and well
height of course the five-legged nylon
legs equipped with five silent caster
wheels so it's easy for you to roll
around
yeah
me and india
it also has a set of built-in
whoa
it also has a set of built-in wireless
speakers so that you can stay immersive
in your gaming all you know play the
sweet sound of victory
[Music]
what's even more cool about this chair
is that the control for the massage
functions are hidden
in the armrest itself
just slide the back and boom so you can
say goodbye to losing the remote
accidental button presses and tripping
over wires with the remote you can
simply choose up to three preset
functions or simply just diy your
controls man so you can either have the
rollers
go a bit lower or higher if you want
some pounding action can be done of
course what osim is doing here is with
his v-hand technology the 360 degree
massage rollers will essentially roll
from your lower back
all the way up to your neck and
shoulders damn
the three preset programs are actually
very comfortable you can definitely get
your shiatsu massage on
and you know doesn't mean
wow
yeah so how does it feel well the chair
itself is pretty comfortable
the seat base has enough give
with
pretty much balance firmness for your
butt so yeah it's pretty comfortable so
with all those good points there is some
stuff to be said first of all the main
gripe is
that it doesn't have a full tilt
mechanism which means you can't really
get the chair up a little bit your butt
and your legs are definitely left out
because this is more focused on your
back and your shoulders but i mean it is
a gaming chair if you really just wanted
a massage chair you can easily get one
right but it's still a great start the
programs are really well done the fact
that you can do it yourself something
that you can customize and cater to your
needs however it would have been nice
for the rollers to have some sort of a
receding function or adjusting the depth
of how these rollers are protruding out
i feel for some people who are a bit
more sensitive to massages
it might get
a little uncomfortable or painful for
the effect it's not really a bad thing
per se but it would have been nice to
have that function second for a chair
that's meant to be rolled around you
have to plug it in if you want to use it
as a massage chair and the amount of
slack you get from the charging adapter
it's only about a meter so it would have
been nice to have at least another half
a meter more just in case you don't have
a plug lying around you might want to
stay stagnant or still because spinning
the chair
would eventually call the cable up and
you know you don't want something to
short or snap and of course it is a
safety hazard because since this is
plug-in you don't want to either drag
your chair away too much or
you know even risking tripping over the
wires giving an extra half a meter or so
for the wires or maybe even go wireless
perhaps there's a
a battery operated one rechargeable
battery operated one who knows we can
only look forward to the version 2 of
this chair another one would be the
armrest i feel that for a little more
extra comfort the armrest should be a
lot wider doesn't go way back to the
elbows maybe have a 4d arm rest so you
can also go from side to side as well
but that's about it really a very solid
gaming chair
with a massage function and boy
do you feel relaxed after i'm still
going on guys it's really that good and
whether it actually boosts your gaming
performance well that is subject to
you know i mean how good or how bad you
are at gaming but i don't think that's
the point honestly i think this chair is
for those who suffer from back eggs or
you even have back problems this could
really help you kind of have two things
in one right a gaming chair as well as a
massage check and if you have the best
of both worlds and if you can afford the
best of both worlds then why not why not
invest in one it's great however if you
already have a gaming chair
you might be better off actually going
for proper proper massage or there are
possibly other cheaper solutions to
outfit your own gaming chair into a
massage chair like those massage pads or
something like that well that's it for
the video we hope you enjoyed it and if
you do give us a thumbs up let us know
in the comments below if
the predator x osim you throne is the
chair for you and if you're getting it
of course and if you haven't already do
[Laughter]
consider subscribing and smash that bell
icon so you can get updated to our
latest unboxings geeky reviews
and more
until then this is okay
[Music]
signing off
[Music]
wahoo
[Music]
yeah okay i'm good
[Music]